Magnifying lenses like the ones in today’s
microscopes gave us, of course, our first
glimpses into the world of the microcosmos.
But it was not the first time people had guessed
that there might be more to the world than
met our eyes, particularly regarding illness.
Marcus Terentius Varro, a Roman scholar in
30 BC, wrote about the need to be cautious
around swamps “because there bred certain
animalculae which cannot be seen by the eyes,
which float in the air and enter the body
through the mouth and nose and there cause
serious diseases.”
Marcus, thus, managed to guess at a reality
that it would take thousands more years, and
a great deal of debate to confirm.
Even now, when it comes to human understanding
of our unseen neighbors, our focus is almost
always driven by negative interactions.
Our most vivid, collective encounters are
also some of the most unpleasant: the sneezing,
the coughing, the upset stomachs, the death
evidence of an apparent tension between our bodies
and the microbial world.
This strange little guy is a parasitic flatworm,
but for now, it’s in its cercarial form,
a larva in search of a host—preferably animals
like duck, geese, and raccoons—where it
can feed on their blood and then mature into
adulthood and release eggs through the infected
animal’s waste.
From the eggs will emerge a ciliated larva
that will seek out particular species of aquatic
snails to serve as an intermediate host as
they develop into their cercarial stage and
complete the cycle.
For all the hosts this parasite will go through,
it turns out that we humans are not a particularly
great one.They can infect us, and when they
do, they will burrow into the skin and create
little bumps, inciting an allergic reaction
that produces a rash formally known as cercarial
dermatitis, but it’s more frequently known
as “swimmer’s itch” thanks to its aquatic
origin.
But for the cercaria, the real challenge is
that we just aren’t the right bodies to
house its development into adulthood, and
instead, it will die.
The word “germs” might be the very first term
many of us learn to describe microbes, an
easy word that warns us from an early age
that there are things we cannot see that nonetheless
we must watch out for.
And with medical necessity often shaping the
direction of scientific research, their potential
danger is further emphasized because it has
inspired and shaped so much of our understanding
of microorganisms.
And so we know a great deal about the microbes
that can hurt us and next to nothing about
the ones that can’t.
But necessity is now driving us to better
grasp the complexity of microbes in relation
to us, the idea that they are only ever enemies
is contradicted by our developing understanding
of the organisms that live in and on us, not
just as freeloaders, but potentially as part
of our body’s mechanics.
Words like “microbiome” and “probiotic”
are now part of our understanding of the world,
and also part of active research, though a
far smaller part than research focused on pathogens.
But, and stop me if you’ve heard this before,
it turns out, the world is bigger than humans,
and beyond our own perimeters, there’s the
importance of microbes to the world around us.
What is known about that world is a tiny percentage
of what there is to know.
Now as we delve more into the balance between
microbes that both help and harm, we do want
to remind you that however harmless or beautiful
or fascinating the microbes we show you here
are, you should still wash your hands and
get your shots, and having done away with
that though, let’s remind you, most microbes
cannot hurt you.
While it would be challenging to calculate
the exact percentage of microbial species
out there that are pathogenic and could potentially
make us sick, estimates put it somewhere less
than 1%.
Figuring out whether the bacteria in our samples
lie in that slim percentage would require
isolating and growing them up in cultures
so that we can sequence and properly identify them.
But we just take the safe route and you know,
we don’t drink the pond water.
Bacterial species do run a range as well,
giving us everything from cheese to tetanus.
For us though, their presence helps sustain
the many bacteria-eaters we feature, and we
keep them fed on droplets of milk, water from
boiled hay, cooked rice, or even liquid plant fertilizer.
Now Nematodes, on the other hand, might seem
like a more clear cut danger.
More commonly known as roundworms, they are
plentiful, with estimates counting them at
around 60 billion nematodes for every person
on Earth, and around 40,000 species in total.
But it’s a select few of those species that
are particularly notorious for humans, able
to enter humans as eggs in contaminated food
or as larva that can penetrate the skin depending
on the species.
So it’s understandable if you respond to
the image of a nematode with some revulsion.
But the vastness of them means that their
impact is so much more complex when you examine
them across their different intersections
with life, from ecosystems where they can
move other microbes around the soil and cycle
nutrients like nitrogen, to agriculture, where
some nematode species may be pests while others
are helpful controls of insect populations.
But these complications aren’t always strictly
about pathogens.
We’ve featured Euglena here before, their twisty
bodies both fascinating and seemingly harmless.
But in 2002, 21,000 striped bass died in a
facility in North Carolina.
The culprit?
A bloom of Euglena sanguinea, which released
a toxin called euglenophycin that is similar
in structure to fire ant venom.
And yet this danger poses a potential
as well, as scientists study the use of euglenophycin
to fight cancer.
And unlike nematodes, which we decidedly do
not want to ingest, there is some culinary
promise for Euglena.
Like Euglena gracilis, which for all of its
small size, manages to pack in large amounts
of proteins and vitamins.
There’s an underlying question in this video
about all these microbes we’ve seen: are
they good?
Or bad?
Or neither?
The answer, of course, varies.
We’re still grasping the extent of what
it means to share a world with organisms that
we weren’t able to even see until a few
centuries ago, dealing not only with the consequences
of their existence but also of our own response
to what we’ve learned.
Understanding bacteria and other microbes,
for example, that helped us usher in the modern
era of antibiotics, which has saved so many
lives.
But antibiotic overuse has also led to the
growing threat of antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
We can’t not try to fight disease or find
uses for microbes, just as we can’t not
interact with the world around us.
The challenge then of making use of our knowledge
responsibly, of categorizing good and bad—whether
at the scale of a microbe or much, much larger—hinges
on our ability to identify our place among
all of this, to better understand the complexities
of the good and the bad of our own actions.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you of course to all of the people who support this channel at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James
check our Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to subscribe to this channel. You should. Do that.